hey guys it's justine and today we are
checking out the brand new
ipad pro i am so excited about this not
only do we have the ipad pro to check
out but we also have the brand new
magic keyboards that come in this nice
white color you may notice that i'm
somewhere different right now i am
actually in my
childhood room at my parents house fully
vaxxed back visiting my parents
it's kind of cool because i'm actually
back where i started making
videos to begin with and today we are
here doing an unboxing
where basically it all started i brought
one of these old school imacs down from
the attic that my parents have saved
that i used to use when i was here
anyway nostalgia aside but the main
highlights in the new ipad pro is the
fact that they put an m1
chip inside of this thing and this is
honestly
super exciting because that's going to
make this thing so incredibly powerful
that it really is setting this ipad up
to be able to do
some really amazing things maybe even
run final cut pro
that is me crossing my fingers and
hoping that one
day that is a reality you can upgrade
the store to two terabytes and
if you get the cellular version they're
also 5g enabled which is
very very exciting have i said that i'm
excited yet because if i didn't i just
want to clarify
i'm excited let's unbox so this is the
12.9 version this is the
largest version that they have it's a
silver
i haven't actually had one of the silver
pros every single time i've been super
into the graphite but now that they have
this white keyboard
i was very excited to check out the
silver
oh my goodness the smell of new
technology
is so exciting one thing that i do wish
they would have integrated into this
is the fingerprint touch id into the
power button like they did in the ipad
air that is honestly one of the best
features that they
really have come out with in a long time
look at this the beautiful shining
shimmering apple logo
i'm like a child christmas morning
like always we have our instructions
power brick
and usbc cable one of the things that
i'm really excited about is being able
to use thunderbolt drives now on
the ipad pro and this is the envoy pro
fx by owc
and owc has been my storage solution for
a very long time so i'm very excited
about this drive specifically because
not only does it have incredibly fast
read write speeds but it's also
very durable so i added almost
exclusively off of external owc
drives so not only is this a drive that
i plan on using with the ipad but i also
use this drive with my computers i'll be
talking a little bit more about this
drive and give you guys a demo of how it
works when i'm editing externally on the
ipad
a huge thank you to owc for hooking me
up with this drive to test out with the
new ipad and for being such an
incredible partner for this video
this magic keyboard honestly changed the
way that i use my ipad when it first
came out and
it came out at a really kind of
interesting time sort of during the
pandemic where
i started using my ipad almost more than
i was using my computer
look at this this white version is so
pretty
and the reason that they call it magic
is because it does have pass-through
charging
in the base right here and you
magnetically attach it to the case and
it sticks and charges
using that pass-through charging open up
little dude oh my gosh it looks so
fresh it's like a snowy day back here in
the east coast this is so clean
i don't even want to touch it it's too
beautiful and pristine
check this out it looks so good
i'm freaking out
oh this keyboard looks so good the
screen looks incredible
i can't wait to get back to california
to be able to connect this to my xdr
display because you can actually connect
these
to the pro display xdrs and get a full
6k output so one ipad has been unboxed
11 inch magic keyboard 11 inch ipad pro
i love the ipad it is just such a
magical little device
the 11 inch is a pretty great size i
will say
like look at this it's perfect charging
brick
usbc like always
having the smaller ipad is definitely
more ideal
for my scenario like this is such a
great great size
i mean look at the size difference it's
pretty significant the fact that i've
been using the 13 inch m1 macbook pro
this is almost the same size as it
almost bigger
than the macbook pro it's a little bit
taller the macbook pro
is a little wider apple pencils
there you go so with this new m1 chip
that is now
in the ipad pros we're going to be
getting 50 faster cpu 40
faster graphics two times faster storage
and the thing i'm really excited about
is the thunderbolt support now which
will allow us
to have faster read write speeds when
we're using an external drive
so we're on set right now and yesterday
we filmed a bunch of unboxings with
these imacs and what's cool was i
already have all of the footage
transferred on to the envoy pro fx
now on my ipad since this is plugged in
and we have thunderbolt support
i can quickly transfer files i can also
edit right here in lumafusion
so here it is i have one of the clips
already imported here and i can
import clips directly from this drive
when i link it all up
and i'm gonna link up imac shoot day one
and here it is like i can edit right
here on my ipad
it's cool because lumafusion is now
going to have multicam support so you'll
be able to edit multicam streams which i
mostly do
two cam shoots every time so look one
two one two
so i can link those up and be able to
edit just like i would on my computer
this is playing back so well too i mean
all of this is
directly from the sony camera four two
two ten bits beautiful
the starting price for the 12.9 inch is
10.99
and the 11 inch is 7.99 in my last ipad
pro review
i did an entire video that i shot
everything on my iphone
and it all in lumafusion once you kind
of get the hang of it and having an
editor that is
kind of created in a touch-based
environment is really
kind of amazing so i'm gonna plug in
my thunderbolt drive give me access to
everything that's on here
what's cool is you have the versatility
to be able to use this drive on various
different platforms
like your imac but also on your ipad
this is the file browser
and i already have a little project here
that i'm gonna bring in
this currently still is in beta so this
is kind of a preview of what's to come
so we're just gonna
create a multi-cam clip and this brings
up all of our different camera angles i
almost always do
shoots with at least two cameras
sometimes three so as you see we have
our a cam
and our b camera here so we're gonna put
camera one here
put camera two right there we have both
of our camera angles all set up and in
this mode
it's really easy to do a live edit so
when i hit play
this is gonna be playing through
whichever screen is selected so i can
just
do a live edit here switch to camera two
switch to camera three
and you can see here this automatically
populates the camera angles
right on the timeline it's great because
lumifesion does have support for hdr so
you can just go in and change your color
space depending upon how this was shot
and what you wanted to be exported as
i've been using the ipads and the brand
new m1 imac for the past couple of days
now and i'm
so excited because not only do i have
this new imac to edit off of
but i've been using this ipad as a
second monitor
i'm so used to being back at home in my
office and having two monitors to work
off of i mostly love having a second
monitor for a file browser so i have all
of my files that i'm kind of sorting
through and my main monitor is where i
have my timeline
and the viewer window to see what i'm
editing the other thing that i found
myself using this for was actually
a hotspot because my parents like i've
mentioned before
do not have the best of internet so i
actually had to drive around
i had my ipad open and was looking for
the best cell service
so all of the videos that you guys are
watching this week i've uploaded those
basically in the middle of the night on
the side of a road in the middle of
nowhere
thanks to this ipad so it's the middle
of the night and i look like i'm doing
some really shady stuff uh but actually
i'm just uploading a youtube video using
the ipad as a hotspot and i think that
my neighbor thinks that
i'm crazy or i'm doing some illegal
activity
literally uploading a youtube video a
new magic keyboard has been slightly
redesigned to fit the new 12.9 inch ipad
pro
you can use your old version of the
magic keyboard but the fit won't be as
perfect
as the new one another really exciting
thing is halide now has an ipad app they
have completely redesigned it and it
looks absolutely beautiful
testing out the halide app it's cool
because you can shoot raw or raw plus
jpeg
and if i want to have the full frame of
my
ipad here i can or i can make it nice
and small
to be able to kind of get the whole
frame in the shot
one feature that doesn't apply to very
many people maybe 10 percent of the
population
is it has a left-handers mode and i am
one of those i'm a left-handed person so
i basically have gone through my life
kind of being left-handed but also
forcing myself to be right-handed so
that i could fit in with society
halide has added this feature so that
you can switch it into left-handed mode
so that the features
are now nicely placed on the left side i
haven't got a chance to test this app
out fully but if you're familiar with
halide it's an incredible iphone app
that has been used
by tons of photographers for so long to
be able to get really amazing raw photos
out of your iphone
another thing that i've been using the
ipad a lot for especially this week i've
been able to use this
as an external monitor so that i can
actually see
what i'm shooting on the camera i did
even use this a lot while we were on set
shooting for the imac video because i
was trying to set up different
shots so as jenna and my friend steve
who was helping me shoot this video
was kind of configuring the camera i was
able to hold onto the ipad and kind of
direct from there so there's so many
different use cases that you can really
use this for
and not just the m1 we have to remember
that even the previous ipads
are still incredibly powerful and a lot
of these things you can do
on those so i don't want you guys to
completely dismiss the fact that a lot
of the things that we're doing
you can do them on the previous
generations obviously this is faster you
have more storage you're going to be
able to have
faster read write speeds with a
thunderbolt drive but for some people it
might be overkill for what they need it
for
i'm not an illustrator but i do have a
design background so i've loved being
able to use procreate just to make
simple mock-ups for logos
and various designs and there's just
something about using the apple pencil
on the ipad that it just
feels like you're drawing on a cloud so
the only real difference between the
12.9 inch and the 11 inch
is the display yes the size difference
is apparent but the 11 inch ipad
has a liquid retin display and the 12.9
is a mini led
liquid retina xdr display and this is
going to give you that 1000 nits of full
brightness when you're viewing hdr
photos or videos
and you can also reach 1 600 nits of
peak brightness on it you'll be able to
view
hdr movies and tv shows but as a content
creator as
i am and i'm sure some of you are as
well will actually be able to edit and
create that content
right here on the ipad pro there's over
10 000 mini leds in this thing and they
are grouped into more than 2500 local
dimming zones
this is going to give us that precise
adjustment of brightness in each zone
the new ipad pro has a new ultra wide
camera built into it
so this is going to help keep you in
frame when you're doing facetime calls
or any other conference that supports
this feature so let's
call jenna how far over can i go
oh that is actual i'm going pretty far
you guys aren't supposed to be seeing
the mess of behind the scenes but you
are
hey do you see me over oh this is my bed
i'm
shooting in my bedroom but do you see
it's following me
center stage dude it's really good for
pacing people who
jump on the phone i know a lot of people
that do that probably a lot of people
watching are probably pacers
when they talk on the phone but i'm
about afraid
oh you just go away all right well
thanks for for being in my beta test
i'm glad it worked bye see ya apple
recently updated their clips app to have
lidar support and obviously
the ipad has lidar built into it i
really love when you first start up the
clips app you have to scan your room and
i feel like for a lot of people they
don't really understand
what lidar really is and it's basically
detecting
depth in the room and with this app it's
a really great visualization so that you
can actually
see this in action this is a really
great update to the app you can also use
this on your iphone as well
and here's our entire scanned area you
can see what it looks like
here okay so here's one of the first
effects
so it's realizing that i'm actually in
the frame and the effects are going
around me but yet still
focusing on the depth map that we've
created of the room and this one's prism
i think this one might be my favorite
here's disco does it look like i'm
having a disco party
question mark dance floor get your body
moving
on it look at these socks look at this
this is pathetic no one's gonna want to
dance with me on the dance floor
and here's some sparkles
stardust and here's the hearts what i
love about this is
these objects are actually seeing that
i'm here
and going around me this is the live
captions feature i love this so much
because it's dictating what i'm saying
as i speak right here onto the video
this is a really great accessibility
feature and i'm surprised how well this
actually works you can even go in after
and edit the auto captions if there's
something that you need to correct
hey jenna do you have a next-gen console
controller by any chance
look at this can you even believe how
quickly that happened
you're now able to connect next-gen
controllers to your ipad
and play games you can also connect this
to your imac and your apple tv as well
which when you kind of think about like
what's happening like this is
a microsoft xbox controller that is
connecting to
my apple imac ipad and apple tv i
love cross-platform compatibility i hope
this doesn't turn on jenna's xbox
which i think it probably is going to
i thought it was going to there's me i
think i'm playing a tutorial i'm sure
use the left sick to steer okay well i
imagine like i know how to do that
my wi-fi is bad no kidding they've
already established that
like i've played this game twice and i'm
incredibly talented
come on come on come on
i am sorry um that i just win yeah i did
well thank you guys so much for watching
i had so much fun getting a chance to
test out this brand new ipad pro
i cannot wait to do some more testing
but i'd love to hear from you guys what
are some use cases that you would like
to see test out that maybe you haven't
seen be tested already
one of the things that's kind of crazy
is the fact that me and my sister
started
our podcast because of the previous gen
ipad pro
i recorded and edited all of it directly
on the ipad it's fun to see what that
podcast turned into it's called same
brain it's on the apple podcast if you'd
like to check it out
we actually just posted our 40th episode
and it features the brand new imacs so
be sure to check it out i'll put a link
in the description if you want to watch
and listen we also have a youtube
channel youtube.combrain and now to kind
of think back that that all was started
because of the ipad is kinda cool i hope
that you enjoyed this video i would love
to hear from you guys what do you think
of the new ipad do you guys have an ipad
do you plan on getting one and if
there's anything else you'd like to see
me test out on this feel free to leave
it in the comments below and i will see
you guys there
[Music]
you